meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
werden sie das geheimnis lüften warum
sie jetzt schon 100.000 abonnenten haben
nein warum sie nach köln gezogen sind
das wird nämlich gefragt im community
video jetzt mit ekrem reloaded und
natürlich noch viel mehr
seid gespannt warten fragte heute ist
euer studium abgebrochen zu haben
ja also das ist eine sehr komplizierte
frage weilenden studium ist heutzutage
ja meistens auch mit ach ich muss er da
hingucken ein studium ist heutzutage mit
geld meistens verbunden und bei uns war
es schon gewisse summe aber also ich
persönlich glaube die anderen beiden
stimmen mir dazu wer bei uns im moment
noch gar nicht weil sich total richtig
so anfühlt wie es jetzt ist und beim
studium hatten wir total wenig zeit um
halt unserem größten hobby oder traum
nachzugehen und deswegen zwar schon eine
richtige entscheidung glaube ich aber
wenn menschen wie die oder welchen
zeitpunkt konnte sie an den statistiken
an den hebel stadt richtigen dann tut
erkennen dass es ernst wird also dass
hier gelernt dass ihr dachtet ok geht's
los jetzt wird's ernst
ja das ist so eine so eine sache man
definiert man dass es losgeht oder dass
wir in statistiken sehen dass es
erfolgreich ich würde sagen wir haben
parodie mal gemacht von katy perry part
of me in der schule gedreht das hat
ultrabook gemacht und so ist das video
auch angekommen
ja ich weiß nicht ob es ab da los ging
aber das war schon so ein schritt nach
vorne würde ich sagen woher us lpga klos
lp mit wie viel geld habt ihr die oma
dazu gekriegt dass sie bei euch mit
macht also wir haben ja zwei unis eine
oma also die erste oma das war die von
andere bezahlen wir kein geld
zweiter oma das war meine da bezahlen
wir natürlich auch kein geld
vielleicht muss man auch sagen die reißt
sich so fast schon darum nochmal
mitzuspielen weil das so geil angekommen
ist ich hab zwei fragen euch und zwar
die erste ist wie habt ihr euch
eigentlich kennengelernt
also ich bin damals mit einem freund der
hieß fabian bruns bin ich zu ihr nach
hause gefahren da kannte ich ja gar
nicht und er hat da das spiel banjo
kazooie gespielt aber dass er war so
frustriert dass er da nicht mehr
weitergekommen ist und ich hab gesagt
hey ich hab das schon durch
blablabla ja ich komme morgen vorbei
dann spielen wir das durch und so hat
das café angefangen wird nintendo ja und
andré das war damals
wir sind dann zusammen in der achten
klasse gewesen und da konnten wir uns
beide noch gar nicht leiden
ja wir waren das dann weißt du das noch
ganz dunkel ich weiß auch nur noch am
anfang da fanden wir uns richtig scheiße
gegenseitig und das hat sich erst nach
einem halben jahr oder so gelegt
ungefähr
ja und das lief dann auch über www also
noch eine nerd story unter dem 1 2 1 1
eine frage an andre wie viele dosen hg
brauchst du damit deine haare so stehen
dass die haare frage kommt ich habe
schon darauf gewartet das bleibt mein
großes geheimnis es ist aber viel
weniger als ihr vielleicht denkt
manchmal ist es sogar so dass andere
aufwacht einmal so macht das kann ich
jetzt natürlich nicht weil ich keine
habe dann stehen hier einfach das volk
und magischer erkennt man ganz gut dass
ihr euch in die haare kriegt und ich
frage mich versteht ihr euch immer noch
so gut dass die weitere gemeinsame
videos machen wollte oder denkt die
manchmal es wäre besser an einen mann
der youtuber zu sein
also eigentlich streiten wir uns nie
wirklich das ist halt so unsere normale
umgangs art und nichts bei denk mir
machen damit immer ganz lang weiter oder
die leute in den lagerbecken sagen immer
in den kommentaren
altair beleidigt euch man hört auf damit
und so und dass davon weil ich zu ernst
nehmen dass es so unsere vielleicht hat
nicht jeder diese art sich zu beleidigen
ständig aber das war uns normal also
denkt euch da nichts also irgendwie
macht doch spaß
probiert es mal aus beleidigte freuen
auch mal dass immer mehr einwohner fragt
andré was bedeutet ein tattoo kannst du
es mal ganz zeigen
das steht in spiegelschrift dass es nur
lesbar ist wenn ich im spiegel gucke auf
latein ich bin wer ich bin und das soll
mich immer daran erinnern zu mir zu
stehen
das ist manchmal nicht ganz so leicht
pikante eigentlich so mehr oder weniger
aus der not heraus weil wir hatten
damals wir haben eigentlich
wow im reallife gedreht was immer super
aufwendig war und viel zeit gefressen
hat und dann hatten wir durch studium
und durch ein paar andere sachen
wirklich keine zeit mehr dafür haben wir
gedacht oh scheiße
wir können das nicht mehr weitermachen
wir brauchen ein konzept irgendwie was
irgendwie noch lustiger und besser ist
als wow in real life aber nicht so viel
zeit kostet und dass ist scheint ja
unmöglich und haben wir uns hingesetzt
waren voll verzweifelt und sind dann
irgendwie innerhalb von fünf minuten
also auf die ganze grund idee gekommen
haben dann ein video davon gedreht und
das hat mehr erfolg gehabt als jede wow
folge glaube ich das erste video like
the boss dass ich ja gar nicht was das
ist
erstes date fil ausrufezeichen glaube
ich und das zweite hieß dann bewerben
like the boss und weil das halt im
selben stil war ist daraus quasi michael
bosse entstanden leute falls ihr so in
der not steckt grübelt immer schön
weiter findet ihr solche konzepte kann o
mania ist neugierig wie soweit ihr nach
köln gezogen verratet das geheimprojekt
da gibt es eigentlich nicht viel zu
verraten ich habe ihm schon geredet
wartet es kommt wir dürfen nichts zu
erzählen
uns sind die hände gebunden also wir
dürfen euch noch noch nichts erzählen
aber seid gespannt es wird auf jeden
fall eine riesen bombe und noch ein
spannendes community video gibt es hier
unten zum anklicken das mit alexei
vecsey
da verrät er nämlich was er essen würde
ich sag nur ein tipp schokolade ist es
nicht genießen würde
oder auch lustig ist das community video
mit h so obst dem erfolgreichen esl
player der berichtet in seinem community
video darüber was sein erstes game war
ja wenn ihr euch das interessiert mich
darauf wenn euch das andere interessiert
geht darauf und ansonsten bislang kann